hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chances.com so in this video i would
like to go through two squeeze plays
that are developing nicely on the
outside which are prog and fissile
so we are in those two place i would
like to show you the reasons why we got
in and what is the exit plan let's get
into it
[Music]
okay let's start with prague p-r-o-g so
i'm gonna go first through technicals
i'm then gonna analyze the option market
as usual very quickly just to sum up the
information for you and i will show you
what we will do here because we are in
display
so maybe the first thing is that i would
like to show you what gave us the
signals that we used to get in so we had
uh here a severe downtrend that buttoned
at 0.6 and the first positive signal was
around 120. so we started to pay
attention to the stock around this level
then then we went to the uh first new
recent high that was at two and here we
got rejected so this was the opportunity
for us to get in we posted this alert on
discord and we got in we bought some
calls we unfortunately went there quite
lightly because at this time the market
there was still a lot of uncertainty in
the market so our position is not big
but uh whatever it's still interesting
to see what is the plan
so we got in on the breakout retest at 1
30 so nice entry and we took our first
profits around 50 of our position at the
resistance line we were having calls so
it's always good to take early profits
on your calls because if nothing happens
you guys know that you're going to pay
the theta we are having uh 2.5
strike november calls so we we we kept
50 of it and we were waiting for a
breakout the breakout happened two days
ago
so this is good this is the signals the
signal we're waiting for
for more upside then yesterday we ran up
close to the four area where we are
actually positioned to exit our full
position i will explain why we don't
target anything higher above that level
first what can we expect from here to
answer that question you can check
the different signals that we have so
first the daily momentum is going higher
okay make the higher this is good i'm
looking for bearish divergences and the
four hours macd is going higher too so
we don't have any divergence on the four
hours on the daily so there is no
immediate signal of reversal we have
support on the breakout area around 250.
as long as we remain above that level
let me check on the four hours and on
the four hours we have the 20 period
moving average which is right now at 240
that acted here perfectly at support so
we expect this to act again as support
this this is why we have a nice support
here so if we see a move below that we
will exit our position and we will
finish closing our profits
but i think that what will happen here
and we might even get bigger let's see
maybe we will increase our position but
what might happen here let me go back on
a daily
the usual behavior of this kind of
breakouts is that you know they are
first rejected because you have some
back holders here that take profits
early and then you have more people
getting back in maybe like we would do
and i think that we can expect a run to
four before either correcting more or
before making your eyes so here you can
say it's a 50 50 situation but
to me it's not a 50 50 situation i will
explain why i think we won't go higher
than this but if i had a bigger position
i would keep
some of my calls to play this level so
if you guys have many calls i would exit
most of it just below four so around 380
and i would keep 20 maximum 30
to play the move to 7.5 let me explain
why so when you go on prague and you
check the synthetic shot first thing we
see is that there is 30 percent of short
in which 10 percent 11 exactly is coming
from the synthetic shot okay now if we
analyze where this position is coming
from
so
okay now it's more than that sorry i
didn't have all the strikes and up here
let me show you guys where it's coming
from so i go to the 10th strike you can
see here the option distribution of the
open interest which is basically showing
you the gamma whenever you have a lot of
options you have a lot of gamma at the
strike and you can see that all the
gamma is coming from the 2.5 strike when
whenever the gamma is big it means the
retail investors position is increasing
when we go through these levels which
means that market makers that are
selling options to retail have their
short position that is increasing as
well because they are on the other side
of the trade so they need to buy shells
on the upside this is what creates this
bullish momentum due to the gamma and
this is the reason why we had here this
breakout because we have a lot of gamma
here so those guys they were really
scared a breakout happens and of course
they have the stop losses just above so
whenever they see the breakout coming
they buy so this is what happens so now
we can see that sometimes we have a lot
of gamma on the upside here the gamma is
at 2.5 and we lose the gamma
progressively at 3 we still have some
gamma so i believe that we would have
the same phenomenon happening 3.5 almost
nothing and 4 we lose everything then we
have some more at 5. so why not but
losing this gamma that sharply here and
only the small amount of options at five
compared to what we have below tells me
that the gamma is fading on the upside
and so that market makers will not be
scared anymore and shorts would probably
increase the position this is the reason
why i don't think we could we're gonna
see uh the price action trading above
four but once again i might be wrong
everything can happen and if we break
four then seven is the natural level i
really really doubt we can go above
7.7 so finishing the profits around 6.57
is a very good idea so this is our plan
on prog once again if you guys are
interested to know what we do the
reasons why we do this just follow us on
discord we are doing live trading we are
making a lot of a lot of analysis on any
stocks you guys are asking us we're also
going to make a very cool game we are
working on it it's going to come soon
you guys are going to be the players and
the winners will of course win some
prizes that we will need to think about
but it's going to be very interactive
it's very cool and the purpose of that
is going to be in the simulation not is
to teach you guys everything that we do
and that we believe can help you in your
trading then second one guys fisela so
this is an energy stock so you guys know
that energy is doing great
this year we have a lot of breakouts on
copper oil gold silver everything that
is related to the energy is looking
great so for this reason we believe in
the stock then technically
technically we got in early guys we have
this one in our live trading portfolio
as well we are loaded of cool options we
have a more decent size here let me go
with you through what happened we've
entered here guys in september our first
trade was in september on this large
volume large breakout okay above this
trend line and we have the bullish
divergence that was coming before so
breakout plus divergence uh plus and we
didn't make a new height that was what
we were missing here okay so for
reversal to happen you check break out
first thing divergences second thing new
high 13. if you have those three and i'm
gonna show you when we had it here then
it's very a very trustful signal
here we only had at this time so
let me do a small replay guys we were
here guys okay i just brought us back in
the past
and here even before we were here guys
okay and we entered on that day
because we were feeling sorry the next
day
up ah too fast
okay we entered on that day guys we had
this and we considered this as a signal
early because we didn't even close above
but the strong volume was meaning
something to us so we entered here then
as you guys know the price action didn't
develop very well no we first went here
got rejected which created a second
trend line so i get rid of this one this
one got broken retested
and we go higher and then here we have
another trend line let me put it in
yellow so here we were like oh okay
it's a shame we didn't do the move right
now then we correct it again and we came
back at it and guys look what happened
here okay let me put the price here here
we posted an alert and we were saying
guys this is looking great because we
were having
here a second breakout okay of this
trendline
with a nice consolidation just below
this is something you guys need to check
whenever you have a consolidation that
is narrow before breakout this brings
energy this means that you can get all
the buyers that were waiting there in
the move so more my more buyers in the
move more money involved more volume
stronger moves and more trustful
breakouts so this is what happened here
and here we decided to enter
again in the same position we had to
increase our position roughly at the
same price and the reason being that
that day the market the pre-market was
above 7.86 so we were having for the
first time
the divergence still with us now we were
having another breakout and a new high
you guys can see in this downtrend one
high two highs
so three eyes okay here it was maybe a
new high already but it was a new high
without breakout here we have breakout
plus a new high above the recent highs
plus the divergence plus a small
consolidation below
and we were only missing the volumes for
that day which we had
so we entered in bigger position here
okay and during that day and we entered
so roughly here around 7.7 we had a nice
run up and so what is the situation now
on this one guys so we have all the
positive signals we have the breakout
the breakout is early so we have a lot
of room i mean i don't see fisell
not going to the 10 area minimum okay we
have the 200 day moving average coming
at 11. so i think that there is a very
high probability we go at least to this
level now as usual we're gonna analyze
so a lot of back holders so you need to
take profits quickly this is what we're
gonna do
uh maybe there's gonna be a crazy move
up but i mean
usually in this kind of situation
there's gonna be a profit taking and
they're gonna be more opportunities if
you want to get back in so this is what
we're gonna play let's check
where the gamma is because once again i
remind you guys that if you follow the
gamma you follow the bullish momentum so
let's follow it let's see where the
gamma is on the start
so how much uh first let me check pro
okay so right now prog has 20 of maximum
synthetic short and i'm gonna check
before because i record everything that
we had okay it dropped heavily guys okay
dropped heavily last time i checked was
when we entered there was seventy
percent of synthetic of maximum
synthetic short so this is one more
reason to tell me that uh prague is
still a play but not for long people are
gonna switch to something else soon i
believe so
profit taking at four makes sense now if
i check fiscello
so fisel first let's check where the ga
where this gamma is coming from so we're
gonna go to the highest strikes because
this is higher and guys where the gamma
is coming from the money all right i
mean 10 we are here we bought some jan
22 10 calls and you can see guess that
we lose the gamma after that okay let me
just show you amc so that you understand
what i mean when i say we lose the gamma
and you're going to see that some stocks
they don't lose the gamma
so this is the difference between
long term swiss plays and short term
squeeze plays
here guys
bam okay
you see you see the difference guys do
you see that the
145 strike the highest strike possible
is the biggest one by far by far this is
the same for gme this is not the same
for all the smaller squeeze plays and
this is the reason why amc is holding
well jimmy is holding well and the other
squeezes they pump and dump
so
let's dump before the other players
right okay so fishel i come back to the
cell so as you see we have
still some
shorts here 20
of total shots let's compare this with
before so sell
okay
increasing oh i don't have any data i
don't know i didn't save it so i don't
know we have ten percent of my maximum
synthetic shorts we have a dtc at two
okay so this is squeezing i mean we are
in the process of a squeeze and once
again i believe so here our exit plan
and we share that with you guys with our
platinum members let's see if if we do
good here but we have many calls and
we're basically going to start taking
profits here for the same reason i don't
think we're going to go much higher than
10 because as you guys can see we lose
the gamma
okay
so 12 a little bit of gamma and then
it's over
okay so the the target area is here and
we're gonna take profits in all this
area so we start here we take more here
we take more here and we finish here we
don't play the this breakout guys okay
this is not the time to play this
breakout you can play this breakout okay
but later
here what might happen in the best case
scenario is that we come here we got
rejected and then we break it so we're
going to have many if you really believe
in the stock don't worry guys they're
going to be many opportunities we're
going to be there to analyze the
situation with you if you're asking us
but one two three four five i don't know
maybe we're starting a new cycle i i
don't care i don't care i take profits
quickly and then i come back in maybe if
i think there is a nice setup once again
to identify a nice setup and this is
what the game is going to be about
you're going to have a choice of
different signals that you guys are
gonna choose the stock you want to buy
and the buying level and then we're
gonna take all this data and show you
who of you guys only on discord
was able to make the best plays and the
winner especially if the winner beats
gabriel or myself and i remind you guys
that we are professional traders
he would get for sure a nice price so
i'm really excited about starting this
game and it's going to be very cool for
you guys because the purpose is that
we're gonna try to show you all the
signals possible that we are looking for
and if you guys have other signals that
we don't know we're gonna be very
interested to analyze it and see if
those signals are good to use or not and
one more thing i wanted to tell you
about guys for those who are interested
to know more about my personal life and
about how things are going in hong kong
just follow me on instagram i put the
link in the description of this video
this is my real account with my real
name so i'm just waiting for you there
and i hope you enjoyed this video and if
you did please guys don't forget to
click on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
shore i see you guys